The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So for the last three
lectures we're going to
talk about classical statistics,
the way statistics
can be done if you don't want to
assume a prior distribution
on the unknown parameters.
Today we're going to focus,
mostly, on the estimation side
and leave hypothesis testing
for the next two lectures.
So where there is one generic
method that one can use to
carry out parameter estimation,
that's the maximum
likelihood method.
We're going to define
what it is.
Then we will look at the most
common estimation problem
there is, which is to estimate
the mean of a given
distribution.
And we're going to talk about
confidence intervals, which
refers to providing an
interval around your
estimates, which has some
properties of the kind that
the parameter is highly likely
to be inside that interval,
but we will be careful about
how to interpret that
particular statement.
Ok.
So the big framework first.
The picture is almost the same
as the one that we had in the
case of Bayesian statistics.
We have some unknown
parameter.
And we have a measuring
device.
There is some noise,
some randomness.
And we get an observation, X,
whose distribution depends on
the value of the parameter.
However, the big change from the
Bayesian setting is that
here, this parameter
is just a number.
It's not modeled as
a random variable.
It does not have a probability
distribution.
There's nothing random
about it.
It's a constant.
It just happens that we don't
know what that constant is.
And in particular, this
probability distribution here,
the distribution of X,
depends on Theta.
But this is not a conditional
distribution in the usual
sense of the word.
Conditional distributions were
defined when we had two random
variables and we condition one
random variable on the other.
And we used the bar to separate
the X from the Theta.
To make the point that this
is not a conditioned
distribution, we use a
different notation.
We put a semicolon here.
And what this is meant to say is
that X has a distribution.
That distribution has
a certain parameter.
And we don't know what
that parameter is.
So for example, this might be
a normal distribution, with
variance 1 but a mean Theta.
We don't know what Theta is.
And we want to estimate it.
Now once we have this setting,
then your job is to design
this box, the estimator.
The estimator is some data
processing box that takes the
measurements and produces
an estimate
of the unknown parameter.
Now the notation that's used
here is as if X and Theta were
one-dimensional quantities.
But actually, everything we
say remains valid if you
interpret X and Theta as
vectors of parameters.
So for example, you
may obtain several
measurements, X1 up to 2Xn.
And there may be several unknown
parameters in the
background.
Once more, we do not have, and
we do not want to assume, a
prior distribution on Theta.
It's a constant.
And if you want to think
mathematically about this
situation, it's as if you
have many different
probabilistic models.
So a normal with this mean or
a normal with that mean or a
normal with that mean, these
are alternative candidate
probabilistic models.
And we want to try to make a
decision about which one is
the correct model.
In some cases, we have to choose
just between a small
number of models.
For example, you have a coin
with an unknown bias.
The bias is either 1/2 or 3/4.
You're going to flip the
coin a few times.
And you try to decide whether
the true bias is this one or
is that one.
So in this case, we have two
specific, alternative
probabilistic models from which
we want to distinguish.
But sometimes things are a
little more complicated.
For example, you have a coin.
And you have one hypothesis
that my coin is unbiased.
And the other hypothesis is
that my coin is biased.
And you do your experiments.
And you want to come up with a
decision that decides whether
this is true or this
one is true.
In this case, we're not
dealing with just two
alternative probabilistic
models.
This one is a specific
model for the coin.
But this one actually
corresponds to lots of
possible, alternative
coin models.
So this includes the model where
Theta is 0.6, the model
where Theta is 0.7, Theta
is 0.8, and so on.
So we're trying to discriminate
between one model
and lots of alternative
models.
How does one go about this?
Well, there's some systematic
ways that one can approach
problems of this kind.
And we will start talking
about these next time.
So today, we're going to focus
on estimation problems.
In estimation problems, theta is
a quantity, which is a real
number, a continuous
parameter.
We're to design this box, so
what we get out of this box is
an estimate.
Now notice that this estimate
here is a random variable.
Even though theta is
deterministic, this is random,
because it's a function of
the data that we observe.
The data are random.
We're applying a function
to the data to
construct our estimate.
So, since it's a function of
random variables, it's a
random variable itself.
The distribution of Theta hat
depends on the distribution of
X. The distribution of X
is affected by Theta.
So in the end, the distribution
of your estimate
Theta hat will also be affected
by whatever Theta
happens to be.
Our general objective, when
designing estimators, is that
we want to get, in the end, an
error, an estimation error,
which is not too large.
But we'll have to make
that specific.
Again, what exactly do
we mean by that?
So how do we go about
this problem?
One general approach is to pick
a Theta, under which the
data that we observe, that
this is the X's, our most
likely to have occurred.
So I observe X. For any given
Theta, I can calculate this
quantity, which tells me, under
this particular Theta,
the X that you observed had this
probability of occurring.
Under that Theta, the X that
you observe had that
probability of occurring.
You just choose that Theta,
which makes the data that you
observed most likely.
It's interesting to compare
this maximum likelihood
estimate with the estimates that
you would have, if you
were in a Bayesian setting,
and you were using maximum
approach theory probability
estimation.
In the Bayesian setting, what
we do is, given the data, we
use the prior distribution
on Theta.
And we calculate the posterior
distribution of Theta given X.
Notice that this is sort
of the opposite from
what we have here.
This is the probability of X
for a particular value of
Theta, whereas this is the
probability of Theta for a
particular X. So it's the
opposite type of conditioning.
In the Bayesian setting, Theta
is a random variable.
So we can talk about
the probability
distribution of Theta.
So how do these two compare,
except for this syntactic
difference that the order X's
and Theta's are reversed?
Let's write down, in full
detail, what this posterior
distribution of Theta is.
By the Bayes rule, this
conditional distribution is
obtained from the prior, and the
model of the measurement
process that we have.
And we get to this expression.
So in Bayesian estimation, we
want to find the most likely
value of Theta.
And we need to maximize
this quantity over
all possible Theta's.
First thing to notice is that
the denominator is a constant.
It does not involve Theta.
So when you maximize this
quantity, you don't care about
the denominator.
You just want to maximize
the numerator.
Now, here, things start to look
a little more similar.
And they would be exactly of
the same kind, if that term
here was absent, it the
prior was absent.
The two are going to become
the same if that prior was
just a constant.
So if that prior is a constant,
then maximum
likelihood estimation takes
exactly the same form as
Bayesian maximum posterior
probability estimation.
So you can give this particular
interpretation of
maximum likelihood estimation.
Maximum likelihood estimation
is essentially what you have
done, if you were in a Bayesian
world, and you had
assumed a prior on the Theta's
that's uniform, all the
Theta's being equally likely.
Okay.
So let's look at a
simple example.
Suppose that the Xi's are
independent, identically
distributed random
variables, with a
certain parameter Theta.
So the distribution of each
one of the Xi's is this
particular term.
So Theta is one-dimensional.
It's a one-dimensional
parameter.
But we have several data.
We write down the formula
for the probability of a
particular X vector, given a
particular value of Theta.
But again, when I use the word,
given, here it's not in
the conditioning sense.
It's the value of the
density for a
particular choice of Theta.
Here, I wrote down, I defined
maximum likelihood estimation
in terms of PMFs.
That's what you would
do if the X's were
discrete random variables.
Here, the X's are continuous
random variables, so instead
of I'm using the PDF
instead of the PMF.
So this a definition, here,
generalizes to the case of
continuous random variables.
And you use F's instead of
X's, our usual recipe.
So the maximum likelihood
estimate is defined.
Now, since the Xi's are
independent, the joint density
of all the X's together
is the product of
the individual densities.
So you look at this quantity.
This is the density or sort of
probability of observing a
particular sequence of X's.
And we ask the question, what's
the value of Theta that
makes the X's that we
observe most likely?
So we want to carry out
this maximization.
Now this maximization is just
a calculational problem.
We're going to do this
maximization by taking the
logarithm of this expression.
Maximizing an expression
is the same as
maximizing the logarithm.
So the logarithm of this
expression, the logarithm of a
product is the sum of
the logarithms.
You get contributions from
this Theta term.
There's n of these, so we
get an n log Theta.
And then we have the sum of the
logarithms of these terms.
It gives us minus Theta.
And then the sum of the X's.
So we need to maximize
this expression
with respect to Theta.
The way to do this maximization
is you take the
derivative, with respect
to Theta.
And you get n over Theta equals
to the sum of the X's.
And then you solve for Theta.
And you find that the
maximum likelihood
estimate is this quantity.
Which sort of makes sense,
because this is the reciprocal
of the sample mean of X's.
Theta, in an exponential
distribution, we know that
it's 1 over (the mean of the
exponential distribution).
So it looks like a reasonable
estimate.
So in any case, this is the
estimates that the maximum
likelihood estimation procedure
tells us that we
should report.
This formula here, of course,
tells you what to do if you
have already observed
specific numbers.
If you have observed specific
numbers, then you observe this
particular number as your
estimate of Theta.
If you want to describe your
estimation procedure more
abstractly, what you have
constructed is an estimator,
which is a box that's takes in
the random variables, capital
X1 up to Capital Xn, and
produces out your estimate,
which is also a random
variable.
Because it's a function of these
random variables and is
denoted by an upper case Theta,
to indicate that this
is now a random variable.
So this is an equality
about numbers.
This is a description of the
general procedure, which is an
equality between two
random variables.
And this gives you the more
abstract view of what we're
doing here.
All right.
So what can we tell about
our estimate?
Is it good or is it bad?
So we should look at this
particular random variable and
talk about the statistical
properties that it has.
What we would like is this
random variable to be close to
the true value of Theta, with
high probability, no matter
what Theta is, since we don't
know what Theta is.
Let's make a little
more specific the
properties that we want.
So we cook up the estimator
somehow.
So this estimator corresponds,
again, to a box that takes
data in, the capital X's,
and produces an
estimate Theta hat.
This estimate is random.
Sometimes it will be above
the true value of Theta.
Sometimes it will be below.
Ideally, we would like it to not
have a systematic error,
on the positive side or
the negative side.
So a reasonable wish to have,
for a good estimator, is that,
on the average, it gives
you the correct value.
Now here, let's be a little more
specific about what that
expectation is.
This is an expectation, with
respect to the probability
distribution of Theta hat.
The probability distribution
of Theta hat is affected by
the probability distribution
of the X's.
Because Theta hat is a
function of the X's.
And the probability distribution
of the X's is
affected by the true
value of Theta.
So depending on which one is the
true value of Theta, this
is going to be a different
expectation.
So if you were to write this
expectation out in more
detail, it would look
something like this.
You need to write down
the probability
distribution of Theta hat.
And this is going to
be some function.
But this function depends on the
true Theta, is affected by
the true Theta.
And then you integrate this
with respect to Theta hat.
What's the point here?
Again, Theta hat is a
function of the X's.
So the density of Theta
hat is affected by the
density of the X's.
The density of the X's
is affected by the
true value of Theta.
So the distribution of Theta
hat is affected by
the value of Theta.
Another way to put it is, as
I've mentioned a few minutes
ago, in this business, it's
as if we are considering
different possible probabilistic
models, one
probabilistic model for
each choice of Theta.
And we're trying to guess
which one of these
probabilistic models
is the true one.
One way of emphasizing the
fact that this expression
depends on the true Theta is
to put a little subscript
here, expectation, under the
particular value of the
parameter Theta.
So depending on what value the
true parameter Theta takes,
this expectation will have
a different value.
And what we would like is that
no matter what the true value
is, that our estimate will not
have a bias on the positive or
the negative sides.
So this is a property
that's desirable.
Is it always going to be true?
Not necessarily, it depends on
what estimator we construct.
Is it true for our exponential
example?
Unfortunately not, the estimate
that we have in the
exponential example turns
out to be biased.
And one extreme way of seeing
this is to consider the case
where our sample size is 1.
We're trying to estimate
Theta.
And the estimator from the
previous slide, in that case,
is just 1/X1.
Now X1 has a fair amount of
density in the vicinity of 0,
which means that 1/X1 has
significant probability of
being very large.
And if you do the calculation,
this ultimately makes the
expected value of 1/X1
to be infinite.
Now infinity is definitely
not the correct value.
So our estimate is
biased upwards.
And it's actually biased
a lot upwards.
So that's how things are.
Maximum likelihood estimates,
in general, will be biased.
But under some conditions,
they will turn out to be
asymptotically unbiased.
That is, as you get more and
more data, as your X vector is
longer and longer, with
independent data, the estimate
that you're going to have, the
expected value of your
estimator is going
to get closer and
closer to the true value.
So you do have some nice
asymptotic properties, but
we're not going to prove
anything like this.
Speaking of asymptotic
properties, in general, what
we would like to have is that,
as you collect more and more
data, you get the correct
answer, in some sense.
And the sense that we're going
to use here is the limiting
sense of convergence in
probability, since this is the
only notion of convergence of
random variables that we have
in our hands.
This is similar to what
we had in the pollster
problem, for example.
If we had a bigger and bigger
sample size, we could be more
and more confident that the
estimate that we obtained is
close to the unknown true
parameter of the distribution
that we have.
So this is a desirable
property.
If you have an infinitely large
amount of data, you
should be able to estimate
an unknown parameter
more or less exactly.
So this is it desirable property
of estimators.
It turns out that maximum
likelihood estimation, given
independent data, does have
this property, under mild
conditions.
So maximum likelihood
estimation, in this respect,
is a good approach.
So let's see, do we have this
consistency property in our
exponential example?
In our exponential example, we
used this quantity to estimate
the unknown parameter Theta.
What properties does
this quantity have
as n goes to infinity?
Well this quantity is the
reciprocal of that quantity up
here, which is the
sample mean.
We know from the weak law of
large numbers, that the sample
mean converges to
the expectation.
So this property here
comes from the weak
law of large numbers.
In probability, this quantity
converges to the expected
value, which, for exponential
distributions, is 1/Theta.
Now, if something converges to
something, then the reciprocal
of that should converge to
the reciprocal of that.
That's a property that's
certainly correct for numbers.
But you're not talking about
convergence of numbers.
We're talking about convergence
in probability,
which is a more complicated
notion.
Fortunately, it turns out that
the same thing is true, when
we deal with convergence
in probability.
One can show, although we will
not bother doing this, that
indeed, the reciprocal of this,
which is our estimate,
converges in probability to
the reciprocal of that.
And that reciprocal is the
true parameter Theta.
So for this particular
exponential example, we do
have the desirable property,
that as the number of data
becomes larger and larger,
the estimate that we have
constructed will get closer
and closer to the true
parameter value.
And this is true no matter
what Theta is.
No matter what the true
parameter Theta is, we're
going to get close to it as
we collect more data.
Okay.
So these are two rough
qualitative properties that
would be nice to have.
If you want to get a little
more quantitative, you can
start looking at the mean
squared error that your
estimator gives.
Now, once more, the comment I
was making up there applies.
Namely, that this expectation
here is an expectation with
respect to the probability
distribution of Theta hat that
corresponds to a particular
value of little theta.
So fix a little theta.
Write down this expression.
Look at the probability
distribution of Theta hat,
under that little theta.
And do this calculation.
You're going to get some
quantity that depends on the
little theta.
And so all quantities in this
equality here should be
interpreted as quantities under
that particular value of
little theta.
So if you wanted to make this
more explicit, you could start
throwing little subscripts
everywhere in those
expressions.
And let's see what those
expressions tell us.
The expected value squared of
a random variable, we know
that it's always equal to the
variance of this random
variable, plus the expectation
of the
random variable squared.
So the expectation value of that
random variable, squared.
This equality here is just our
familiar formula, that the
expected value of X squared is
the variance of X plus the
expected value of X squared.
So we apply this formula
to X equal to
Theta hat minus Theta.
Now, remember that, in this
classical setting, theta is
just a constant.
We have fixed Theta.
We want to calculate the
variance of this quantity,
under that particular Theta.
When you add or subtract a
constant to a random variable,
the variance doesn't change.
This is the same as the variance
of our estimator.
And what we've got here is
the bias of our estimate.
It tells us, on the average,
whether we
fall above or below.
And we're taking the bias
to be b squared.
If we have an unbiased
estimator, the bias
term will be 0.
So ideally we want Theta hat
to be very close to Theta.
And since Theta is a constant,
if that happens, the variance
of Theta hat would
be very small.
So Theta is a constant.
If Theta hat has a distribution
that's
concentrated just around own
little theta, then Theta hat
would have a small variance.
So this is one desire
that have.
We're going to have
a small variance.
But we also want to have a small
bias at the same time.
So the general form of the mean
squared error has two
contributions.
One is the variance
of our estimator.
The other is the bias.
And one usually wants to design
an estimator that
simultaneously keeps both
of these terms small.
So here's an estimation method
that would do very well with
respect to this term,
but badly with
respect to that term.
So suppose that my distribution
is, let's say,
normal with an unknown mean
Theta and variance 1.
And I use as my estimator
something very dumb.
I always produce an estimate
that says my estimate is 100.
So I'm just ignoring the
data and report 100.
What does this do?
The variance of my
estimator is 0.
There's no randomness in the
estimate that I report.
But the bias is going
to be pretty bad.
The bias is going to be Theta
hat, which is 100 minus the
true value of Theta.
And for some Theta's, my bias
is going to be horrible.
If my true Theta happens
to be 0, my bias
squared is a huge term.
And I get a large error.
So what's the moral
of this example?
There are ways of making that
variance very small, but, in
those cases, you pay a
price in the bias.
So you want to do something a
little more delicate, where
you try to keep both terms
small at the same time.
So these types of considerations
become
important when you start to try
to design sophisticated
estimators for more complicated
problems.
But we will not do this
in this class.
This belongs to further
classes on
statistics and inference.
For this class, for parameter
estimation, we will basically
stick to two very
simple methods.
One is the maximum likelihood
method we've just discussed.
And the other method is what you
would do if you were still
in high school and didn't
know any probability.
You get data.
And these data come from
some distribution
with an unknown mean.
And you want to estimate
that the unknown mean.
What would you do?
You would just take those data
and average them out.
So let's make this a little
more specific.
We have X's that come from
a given distribution.
We know the general form of
the distribution, perhaps.
We do know, perhaps, the
variance of that distribution,
or, perhaps, we don't know it.
But we do not know the mean.
And we want to estimate the
mean of that distribution.
Now, we can write
this situation.
We can represent it in
a different form.
The Xi's are equal to Theta.
This is the mean.
Plus a 0 mean random
variable, that you
can think of as noise.
So this corresponds to the usual
situation you would have
in a lab, where you
go and try to
measure an unknown quantity.
You get lots of measurements.
But each time that you measure
them, your measurements have
some extra noise in there.
And you want to kind of
get rid of that noise.
The way to try to get rid of
the measurement noise is to
collect lots of data and
average them out.
This is the sample mean.
And this is a very, very
reasonable way of trying to
estimate the unknown
mean of the X's.
So this is the sample mean.
It's a reasonable, plausible,
in general, pretty good
estimator of the unknown mean
of a certain distribution.
We can apply this estimator
without really knowing a lot
about the distribution
of the X's.
Actually, we don't need to
know anything about the
distribution.
We can still apply it, because
the variance, for example,
does not show up here.
We don't need to know
the variance to
calculate that quantity.
Does this estimator have
good properties?
Yes, it does.
What's the expected value
of the sample mean?
If the expectation of this, it's
the expectation of this
sum divided by n.
The expected value for each
one of the X's is Theta.
So the expected value
of the sample mean
is just Theta itself.
So our estimator is unbiased.
No matter what Theta is, our
estimator does not have a
systematic error in
either direction.
Furthermore, the weak law of
large numbers tells us that
this quantity converges to the
true parameter in probability.
So it's a consistent
estimator.
This is good.
And if you want to calculate
the mean squared error
corresponding to
this estimator.
Remember how we defined the
mean squared error?
It's this quantity.
Then it's a calculation that we
have done a fair number of
times by now.
The mean squared error is the
variance of the distribution
of the X's divided by n.
So as we get more and more data,
the mean squared error
goes down to 0.
In some examples, it turns out
that the sample mean is also
the same as the maximum
likelihood estimate.
For example, if the X's are
coming from a normal
distribution, you can write down
the likelihood, do the
maximization with respect to
Theta, you'll find that the
maximum likelihood estimate is
the same as the sample mean.
In other cases, the sample mean
will be different from
the maximum likelihood.
And then you have a choice
about which one of the
two you would use.
Probably, in most reasonable
situations, you would just use
the sample mean, because it's
simple, easy to compute, and
has nice properties.
All right.
So you go to your boss.
And you report and say,
OK, I did all my
experiments in the lab.
And the average value that I got
is a certain number, 2.37.
So is that the informative
to your boss?
Well your boss would like to
know how much they can trust
this number, 2.37.
Well, I know that the true
value is not going to be
exactly that.
But how close should it be?
So give me a range of
what you think are
possible values of Theta.
So the situation is like this.
So suppose that we observe X's
that are coming from a certain
distribution.
And we're trying to
estimate the mean.
We get our data.
Maybe our data looks something
like this.
You calculate the mean.
You find the sample mean.
So let's suppose that the sample
mean is a number, for
some reason take to be 2.37.
But you want to convey something
to your boss about
how spread out these
data were.
So the boss asks you to give
him or her some kind of
interval on which Theta, the
true parameter, might lie.
So the boss asked you
for an interval.
So what you do is you end up
reporting an interval.
And you somehow use the data
that you have seen to
construct this interval.
And you report to your
boss also the
endpoints of this interval.
Let's give names to
these endpoints,
Theta_n- and Theta_n+.
The ends here just play the role
of keeping track of how
many data we're using.
So what you report to your boss
is this interval as well.
Are these Theta's here, the
endpoints of the interval,
lowercase or uppercase?
What should they be?
Well you construct these
intervals after
you see your data.
You take the data into account
to construct your interval.
So these definitely should
depend on the data.
And therefore they are
random variables.
Same thing with your estimator,
in general, it's
going to be a random variable.
Although, when you go and report
numbers to your boss,
you give the specific
realizations of the random
variables, given the
data that you got.
So instead of having
just a single box
that produces estimates.
So our previous picture was that
you have your estimator
that takes X's and produces
Theta hats.
Now our box will also be
producing Theta hats minus and
Theta hats plus.
It's going to produce
an interval as well.
The X's are random, therefore
these quantities are random.
Once you go and do the
experiment and obtain your
data, then your data
will be some
lowercase x, specific numbers.
And then your estimates
and estimator
become also lower case.
What would we like this
interval to do?
We would like it to be highly
likely to contain the true
value of the parameter.
So we might impose some specs
of the following kind.
I pick a number, alpha.
Usually that alpha,
think of it as a
probability of a large error.
Typical value of alpha might
be 0.05, in which case this
number here is point 0.95.
And you're given specs that
say something like this.
I would like, with probability
at least 0.95, this to happen,
which says that the true
parameter lies inside the
confidence interval.
Now let's try to interpret
this statement.
Suppose that you did the
experiment, and that you ended
up reporting to your boss
a confidence interval
from 1.97 to 2.56.
That's what you report
to your boss.
And suppose that the confidence
interval has this property.
Can you go to your boss and say,
with probability 95%, the
true value of Theta is between
these two numbers?
Is that a meaningful
statement?
So the statement is, the
tentative statement is, with
probability 95%, the true
value of Theta is
between 1.97 and 2.56.
Well, what is random
in that statement?
There's nothing random.
The true value of theta
is a constant.
1.97 is a number.
2.56 is a number.
So it doesn't make any sense to
talk about the probability
that theta is in
this interval.
Either theta happens to be
in that interval, or it
happens to not be.
But there are no probabilities
associated with this.
Because theta is not random.
Syntactically, you
can see this.
Because theta here
is a lower case.
So what kind of probabilities
are we talking about here?
Where's the randomness?
Well the random thing
is the interval.
It's not theta.
So the statement that is being
made here is that the
interval, that's being
constructed by our procedure,
should have the property that,
with probability 95%, it's
going to fall on top of the
true value of theta.
So the right way of interpreting
what the 95%
confidence interval is, is
something like the following.
We have the true value of theta
that we don't know.
I get data.
Based on the data, I construct
a confidence interval.
I get my confidence interval.
I got lucky.
And the true value of
theta is in here.
Next day, I do the same
experiment, take my data,
construct a confidence
interval.
And I get this confidence
interval, lucky once more.
Next day I get data.
I use my data to come up with
an estimate of theta and the
confidence interval.
That day, I was unlucky.
And I got a confidence
interval out there.
What the requirement here is, is
that 95% of the days, where
we use this certain procedure
for constructing confidence
intervals, 95% of those days,
we will be lucky.
And we will capture the correct
value of theta by your
confidence interval.
So it's a statement about the
distribution of these random
confidence intervals, how likely
are they to fall on top
of the true theta, as opposed
to how likely
they are to fall outside.
So it's a statement about
probabilities associated with
a confidence interval.
They're not probabilities about
theta, because theta,
itself, is not random.
So this is what the confidence
interval is, in general, and
how we interpret it.
How do we construct a 95%
confidence interval?
Let's go through this
exercise, in
a particular example.
The calculations are exactly the
same as the ones that you
did when we talked about laws
of large numbers and the
central limit theorem.
So there's nothing new
calculationally but it's,
perhaps, new in terms of the
language that we use and the
interpretation.
So we got our sample mean
from some distribution.
And we would like to calculate
a 95% confidence interval.
We know from the normal tables,
that the standard
normal has 2.5% on the tail,
that's after 1.96.
Yes, by this time,
the number 1.96
should be pretty familiar.
So if this probability
here is 2.5%, this
number here is 1.96.
Now look at this random
variable here.
This is the sample mean.
Difference, from the true mean,
normalized by the usual
normalizing factor.
By the central limit theorem,
this is approximately normal.
So it has probability 0.95
of being less than 1.96.
Now take this event here
and rewrite it.
This the event, well, that
Theta hat minus theta is
bigger than this number and
smaller than that number.
This event here is equivalent
to that event here.
And so this suggests a way of
constructing our 95% percent
confidence interval.
I'm going to report the
interval, which gives this as
the lower end of the confidence
interval, and gives
this as the upper end of
the confidence interval
In other words, at the end of
the experiment, we report the
sample mean, which
is our estimate.
And we report also, an interval
around the sample mean.
And this is our 95% confidence
interval.
The confidence interval becomes
smaller, when n is larger.
In some sense, we're more
certain that we're doing a
good estimation job, so we can
have a small interval and
still be quite confident that
our interval captures the true
value of the parameter.
Also, if our data have very
little noise, when you have
more accurate measurements,
you're more confident that
your estimate is pretty good.
And that results in a smaller
confidence interval, smaller
length of the confidence
interval.
And still you have 95%
probability of capturing the
true value of theta.
So we did this exercise by
taking 95% confidence
intervals and the corresponding
value from the
normal tables, which is 1.96.
Of course, you can do it more
generally, if you set your
alpha to be some other number.
Again, you look at the
normal tables.
And you find the value here,
so that the tail has
probability alpha over 2.
And instead of using these 1.96,
you use whatever number
you get from the
normal tables.
And this tells you
how to construct
a confidence interval.
Well, to be exact, this
is not necessarily a
95% confidence interval.
It's approximately a 95%
confidence interval.
Why is this?
Because we've done
an approximation.
We have used the central
limit theorem.
So it might turn out to be a
95.5% confidence interval
instead of 95%, because
our calculations are
not entirely accurate.
But for reasonable values of
n, using the central limit
theorem is a good
approximation.
And that's what people
almost always do.
So just take the value from
the normal tables.
Okay, except for one catch.
I used the data.
I obtained my estimate.
And I want to go to my boss and
report this theta minus
and theta hat, which is the
confidence interval.
What's the difficulty?
I know what n is.
But I don't know what sigma
is, in general.
So if I don't know sigma,
what am I going to do?
Here, there's a few options
for what you can do.
And the first option is familiar
from what we did when
we talked about the
pollster problem.
We don't know what sigma is,
but maybe we have an upper
bound on sigma.
For example, if the Xi's
Bernoulli random variables, we
have seen that the standard
deviation is at most 1/2.
So use the most conservative
value for sigma.
Using the most conservative
value means that you take
bigger confidence intervals
than necessary.
So that's one option.
Another option is to try to
estimate sigma from the data.
How do you do this estimation?
In special cases, for special
types of distributions, you
can think of heuristic ways
of doing this estimation.
For example, in the case of
Bernoulli random variables, we
know that the true value of
sigma, the standard deviation
of a Bernoulli random variable,
is the square root
of theta1 minus theta,
where theta is
the mean of the Bernoulli.
Try to use this formula.
But theta is the thing we're
trying to estimate in the
first place.
We don't know it.
What do we do?
Well, we have an estimate for
theta, the estimate, produced
by our estimation procedure,
the sample mean.
So I obtain my data.
I get my data.
I produce the estimate
theta hat.
It's an estimate of the mean.
Use that estimate in this
formula to come up with an
estimate of my standard
deviation.
And then use that standard
deviation, in the construction
of the confidence interval,
pretending
that this is correct.
Well the number of your data is
large, then we know, from
the law of large numbers, that
theta hat is a pretty good
estimate of theta.
So sigma hat is going to be a
pretty good estimate of sigma.
So we're not making large errors
by using this approach.
So in this scenario here, things
were simple, because we
had an analytical formula.
Sigma was determined by theta.
So we could come up
with a quick and
dirty estimate of sigma.
In general, if you do not have
any nice formulas of this
kind, what could you do?
Well, you still need
to come up with an
estimate of sigma somehow.
What is a generic method for
estimating a standard deviation?
Equivalently, what could be a
generic method for estimating
a variance?
Well the variance is
an expected value
of some random variable.
The variance is the mean of the
random variable inside of
those brackets.
How does one estimate the mean
of some random variable?
You obtain lots of measurements
of that random
variable and average them out.
So this would be a reasonable
way of estimating the variance
of a distribution.
And again, the weak law of large
numbers tells us that
this average converges to the
expected value of this, which
is just the variance of
the distribution.
So we got a nice and
consistent way
of estimating variances.
But now, we seem to be getting
in a vicious circle here,
because to estimate
the variance, we
need to know the mean.
And the mean is something we're
trying to estimate in
the first place.
Okay.
But we do have an estimate
from the mean.
So a reasonable approximation,
once more, is to plug-in,
here, since we don't
know the mean, the
estimate of the mean.
And so you get that expression,
but with a theta
hat instead of theta itself.
And this is another
reasonable way of
estimating the variance.
It does have the same
consistency properties.
Why?
When n is large, this is going
to behave the same as that,
because theta hat converges
to theta.
And when n is large, this is
approximately the same as
sigma squared.
So for a large n, this quantity
also converges to
sigma squared.
And we have a consistent
estimate of
the variance as well.
And we can take that consistent
estimate and use it
back in the construction
of confidence interval.
One little detail, here,
we're dividing by n.
Here, we're dividing by n-1.
Why do we do this?
Well, it turns out that's what
you need to do for these
estimates to be an unbiased
estimate of the variance.
One has to do a little bit of
a calculation, and one finds
that that's the factor that you
need to have here in order
to be unbiased.
Of course, if you get 100 data
points, whether you divide by
100 or divided by 99, it's
going to make only a tiny
difference in your estimate
of your variance.
So it's going to make only
a tiny difference in your
estimate of the standard
deviation.
It's not a big deal.
And it doesn't really matter.
But if you want to show off
about your deeper knowledge of
statistics, you throw in the
1 over n-1 factor in there.
So now one basically needs to
put together this story here,
how you estimate the variance.
You first estimate
the sample mean.
And then you do some extra
work to come up with a
reasonable estimate of
the variance and
the standard deviation.
And then you use your estimate,
of the standard
deviation, to come up with a
confidence interval, which has
these two endpoints.
In doing this procedure, there's
basically a number of
approximations that
are involved.
There are two types
of approximations.
One approximation is that we're
pretending that the
sample mean has a normal
distribution.
That's something we're justified
to do, by the
central limit theorem.
But it's not exact.
It's an approximation.
And the second approximation
that comes in is that, instead
of using the correct standard
deviation, in general, you
will have to use some
approximation of
the standard deviation.
Okay so you will be getting a
little bit of practice with
these concepts in recitation
and tutorial.
And we will move on to
new topics next week.
But the material that's going
to be covered in the final
exam is only up to this point.
So next week is just
general education.
Hopefully useful, but it's
not in the exam.